[Applaudissements]
maintenant on passe à la poésie à
l'émotion avec le mime osé le mime osé
celui qui ose les gestes les plus fous à
5 ans il lui met un pouce c'est
tellement bien fait qu'il ait su c'est
par toute une crèche
à 12 ans il mime un stérilet et on doit
éventré sa soeur pour le dégager
mesdames et messieurs je vous demande de
faire un triomphe au mime osé alors mais
ma vous revenez avec votre personnage de
base but je crois
beat est un personnage que j'ai pris en
main très tôt dès l'adolescence et à
force de le triturer de le malaxer il a
fini par prendre forme
j'ai compris que je tenais là mon
personnage de base celui qu'elle aime
permettent de communiquer mon amour des
hommes ma passion de transmettre mon
virus en quelque sorte à bien et vous
venu nous présenter un extrait de quand
un homme rencontre une âme
elle vient place à la poésie place à
l'émotion avec le mime osé
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
e
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]